back in 2015 who have won Dancing with
the Stars well this season 23 year old
Jordan and Lindsay are the front-right
and I'm just so they're the only ones to
get perfect scores this week they're the
ones to beat but no no they are amazing
together so how do you improve on
perfection I drop by their rehearsal
this morning to find out semi-finals
everyone are you nervous
has it hit you are you ready to win I
think all yes eyes yeah yes to all of
that who do you think could be you hate
this point it is anybody dancing alone
isn't gonna win it so we're trying to
make sure that we give everything to
America so they want us to win is it
crazy to think that you have to break up
in two weeks I don't know I don't know
it's really weird that is I will say
that that is the weirdest thing though
the show is like you spent every day day
in day out being stressed together
working hard together Nelson looks like
separation anxiety luckily we live close
what we'll definitely stay in touch yeah
but Jordan is looking forward to being
able to spend more time with his partner
outside the ballroom girlfriend Ellie
Ellie and I have been together
officially for almost a year but we've
we've been best friends for 11 years we
grew up together we met in Birmingham at
a dad theatre conservatory that we both
worked at a lot of pros a lot of
contestants everyone's heading down the
aisle are you getting bed Dancing with
the Stars married edge do you think
she's definitely my person she's
definitely the one that yeah there's
there's no no question of am i no doubt
about the matter of timing so you win
the Mirrorball and then you put the
Mirrorball on the finger that'd be a
nice little
you